intellectuellement, c'était extrêmement difficile d'
être un décrocheur du secondaire jouant maintenant
un professeur à l'université, c'était un peu
exagéré, mais quelque chose qui m'excitait,
je ne suis jamais quelqu'un qui a vraiment
hésité devant un défi, j'ai l'habitude de
sauter sur l'occasion de  faire quelque chose de
différent et d'inattendu mais je suis aussi
le genre de gars qui va s'assurer
que je suis prêt la première chose que je
voulais faire était de passer autant de temps que possible avec
des professeurs de littérature
alors nous avons mis en place une lecture de  le scénario
avec le chef du département d'anglais
de l'Université du Michigan et il a lu
le scénario à haute voix pour nous et j'ai commencé à
travailler dessus en août, nous n'avons pas
commencé à tourner Jo en janvier, mais je
lisais littéralement le scénario à haute voix deux fois
un jour tous les jours, puis la transformation physique,
il y avait deux façons de procéder,
soit j'allais essayer de devenir aussi
lourd que possible et le studio n'aimait pas
tellement cette idée, alors j'ai dit d'
accord, nous irons le mince r  oute sortant des
transformateurs le film avant la douleur et le
gain de son physique est très musclé
et construit et il joue un
professeur d'université à Penn, c'est évidemment beaucoup plus mental
que physique, donc je voulais
faire quelque chose de physique à sa
masse corporelle qui serait juste vous nous
s'éloignerait de l'un des
rôles physiques de Mark Wahlberg et entrerait beaucoup plus dans un
autre type de physique de loup beaucoup plus maigre
et il est l'un de
ces acteurs qui fera un effort supplémentaire
qui ira vous savez que ce n'est pas
facile à dessiner  soixante quelque chose livres et
il l'a fait dans une
période de temps extraordinairement courte quand euh vous connaissez le
régime liquide pendant quelques mois et
sauter beaucoup de corde et faire tout ce que je pouvais
pour devenir aussi mince que possible à partir du
moment où vous le voyez à l'écran  pour la
première fois, cela lui donne juste un
personnage différent et ce genre de déverrouille
immédiatement la porte dans le personnage et
cela l'aide en tant qu'interprète à trouver le
personnage plus facilement  et je pense que cela
aide le public à comprendre
qu'il s'agit d'une performance plus mentale
que physique